hello
people who are free at least for now
it's me your host who is free at least
for now dave rubin
today is december 7th 2020 this is the
reuben report
direct message and we're doing all
lockdown edition
of the direct message today everything
that i'm doing today is about the
lockdown we're putting aside the
election stuff
for a little bit there's obviously a lot
going on there and things working
through the courts and the rest of it
uh but i sense something big is
happening on the lockdown front there
there is a major
major pushback against what's going on
and i thought we should just devote the
whole show to it with a whole bunch of
different clips
from different cities different states
people fighting for their rights i also
spent
this weekend at some rallies and
i just feel like people
have had it and they're pushing back and
that really is
the most american thing that you can do
let's not forget i am live
in los angeles where as of i believe
this morning or or like midnight last
night
we are now under full lockdown they
don't want you walking your dog they
don't want you roller skating they don't
want you
biking they don't want you doing pretty
much anything they want you to sit alone
and depressed and pathetic and neutered
i refuse to do that i've got a couple
people
in the room with me right now come and
get me garcetti come and get me
i actually this weekend not only did i
go to one of the rallies we'll we'll
talk about that in just a second
but because it was important that you
only do vital
things you know i mean really vital
things i uh yesterday morning
ordered nba jam remember nba jam from
the
early mid 90's the uh the amazing arcade
game nba jam well now you can get a home
version of the arcade game it's only 500
bucks
i ordered it and picked it up at best
buy but i felt that that was
vital for me because you've got nba jam
on there you've got like nba jam
tournament edition and then one other
one and i put it together yesterday and
you can play wi-fi
and david and i beat my brother and my
ten-year-old nephew it's like one of the
first times i've been able to beat my
nephew in anything so i'm very excited
and that was what's
vital for me to stay alive all right so
you know what instead of running down
all the stories which i normally do at
the top of the show
we're just gonna plow into them uh
because they're all just one after the
other
lockdown related things so we showed you
a video oh
you know what real quick before i get
into that fully uh our
direct message on friday was our most
watched direct message ever about 800
000 views on youtube alone that's not
that doesn't include what's going on at
the reuben report community
and on theblaze.com and i just want to
say that i'm i'm thrilled so many of
new people so many of you who are new
are here
and obviously what we're talking about
and trying to noodle through these
issues in an honest way
it matters and more of you guys are
sharing the videos and commenting on
them and all that good stuff so i
appreciate it i thank you
and i'll do my best uh not to let you
down
okay so uh we showed a video last week
this was
a woman by the name of angela marsden
and she
is the owner of pineapple hill
restaurant and
bar in sherman oaks california in los
angeles in effect in the valley
and she showed we showed the video but
she basically did a selfie video of her
restaurant
and the fact that they had closed her
down not only inside but even though she
did all of this stuff to make a really
nice outdoor area they closed her down
but then right next to that they were
allowing
um a movie or a tv show i think it was a
tv show actually like a netflix show
set up tents for their people to eat so
those people
are essential but apparently she's not
essential well i actually went to the
rally that she was at and i interviewed
her we put up a video over the weekend
about that but let's take a look quick
at the
just like a 20-second bite of the
original video
and then we'll go from there
so this is my place the pineapple hill
grill in saloon if you go to my page you
can see all the work i did
for outdoor dining for tables being
seven feet apart
and i come in today because i'm
organizing a protest
and i came in to get stuff for that
and i walk into my parking lot and
obviously
brevity's sake we're not going to show
you the whole thing right now but we
showed it all
on friday and i interviewed her on
saturday so what happened was as i said
in the parking lot there you see she
sets her outside stuff
and then if you watch the end of the
video they show you that oh if you're a
tv production you're allowed to sit
outside neat but they aren't as if any
of this has to do with science
as if any of this has to do with
anything constitutional or sensible
or anything else so sheila and a bunch
of people because i'm sorry not sheila
sheila's the woman we'll get to in just
a minute angela
because that video went so viral and i'd
like to think that i had a little
something to do with it
uh they did a big rally on saturday at
the house of sheila cool now sheila cool
i had talked about last week because she
was one of the five
city supervisors who voted just last
week
to close everything right that's what
allowed
uh fuhrer garcetti to close everything
and in effect they voted
three to two to close all of the
restaurants and then sheila cool this
woman who makes over
three hundred thousand dollars a year
three hundred thousand dollars a year to
just be a government
nothing to just be a middle man who
controls people's lives
who are actually producing she voted
three to two so she was the deciding
vote to shut down all the restaurants
and then as we talked about last week
what did she do
she went to an outdoor restaurant even
though she was gonna close them all down
in a few days but it was so
uh severe what's happening with kobet
it's so dangerous we've got to
crush all of these 31 000 restaurants
that we have in los angeles in socal
and but she could just get one last
quick italian meal
in there so these people are hypocrites
and angela
and a bunch of people organized a rally
at sheila's house now i don't like doing
these things at people's houses
i i actually when i got there i said to
angel oh i wish we would have done this
at your restaurant i even offered her a
thousand bucks i was just gonna
buy people food but there was just too
many things happening to to do it at
once but if she wants to do that
angela i'm guessing you're probably
watching now and we're texting so uh
that offer still stands um but in any
event they did it at sheila cool's house
couple hundred people came
a bunch of a bunch of press was there
we've got a bunch of
photographs that i think we're laying in
as i'm discussing some of this stuff
and and it was it was just incredible
because you really need to understand
that the people that are showing up to
these things i met several other
restaurant owners and other business
owners
these are not radicals many of them
probably um two months ago didn't think
of themselves as trump supporters
although i think a lot of them are
rethinking it right now i don't think
these are particularly political people
these are just people who want to go out
and live that's all they are i met a guy
who owns 39 restaurants
in la employs about a thousand people
he's had to lay off about 800 people
he now said he's going to run for county
supervisor which is
a cool sheila cool's job so people
are getting involved and they're pushing
us it's like you're just
pushing pushing pushing on good people
uh i don't know if we showed it already
but we can also throw up the image
of me signing the petition yeah we did
of me signing the petition to
recall gavin newsom and it's a very
complex situation and if your pen
literally touches the line it doesn't
count like a whole bunch of
a whole bunch of stuff but i signed the
petition to get rid of newsome who's
just a horrific horrific governor
and our awful mayor here in new york
city and again uh here in los angeles
and again
these are just good people these aren't
political people they don't want to hurt
anybody they want to be able to live and
to meet all of these people
who've dedicated their lives to
something to build something and then
just
watch bureaucrats take it away knowing
that there's no science behind it it's
it's uh i feel different actually than
i've felt over the last couple days you
know i was sort of more annoyed than
usual last week
and this week i'm feeling some kind of
like righteous indignation like we've
got to fix this and no one's coming
to save us guys no one is coming to save
us if you think some good guys are
coming and the avengers are going to
assemble
they aren't you're the avengers now and
you got to push back so eric garcetti
let's throw a couple quotes in
from mr mayor he said my heart goes out
to ms
marsden and the workers at pineapple
hill saloon who have to comply with the
state
and county public health restrictions
that close outdoor dining
no one likes these restrictions but i do
support them as our hospital icu beds
fill to capacity in cases of increased
500 percent
we have to stop this virus before it
kills thousands of more angelenos now we
showed you a chart
on friday about icu uh the amount of
beds that are taken in icu and in the
regular hospitals and
although they are now going up again
they have never gotten close to being
overwhelmed here in los angeles
as far as i know we haven't had anywhere
in the united states where
hospitals have really been overwhelmed
that means we've done something
good that means people do wear masks
that means
you know businesses are acting
responsibly and again
guys and don't forget it because they're
gonna try to make you memory whole
everything 1984.
in march we were told two weeks to
flatten the curve does this
feel like this is about covet anymore
does it feel like it's about something
else and
and also just think about it this way
and this is what you need to bring up
when you're when your crazy uncle or
whoever is screaming at you about this
stuff
we have some states like florida in
particular texas
red states that are opened up they're
much more opened up people are doing
what's responsible
whatever they feel is right for their
lives and then we have these states in
severe lockdown like california
now why are the numbers not wildly out
of control
if they are please show me but nobody
seems to be able to show me right
if if this is to be true if all of this
is to be true follow the science and all
that well one state's opening up they're
letting people do what they want people
are eating out they're talking to each
other they're singing during holidays
well shouldn't those numbers be
exploding not not just a little bit
higher
or just comparable but shouldn't those
numbers be exploding
while these are going down and then if
that was the case wouldn't people from
red states florida and texas be
fleeing there's a mass outbreak of a
disease that's killing everybody we have
no hospital beds or any of those
wouldn't they be fleeing to the
sanctuary of blue states
but aha ironically that's not happening
obviously you all know what's happening
which is that people in blue states
are fleeing to go to red states to be
freer and live their lives and save on
taxes
and everything else so someone like like
sometimes they'll tell you to follow the
science which which really at this point
means almost nothing
and i watched a video this morning of
andrew cuomo and fauci
giggling for like five minutes about
which one of them is de niro and which
one of them is pesci or something
they're just laughing like they're this
fun duo now and it's like you guys are
all just
gross these people are gross and this is
about control it has almost nothing
to do at this point uh with covid but
all right
i've been talking about l.a in
california let's get to the other coast
so we also
talked about the story last week in
staten island
and i should mention that one of the
things that i'm really going to try to
do with this show and i think we're
doing a pretty decent job of it so far
is that you know one of the things that
happens in news is you get a story and
then you never find out what else
happens right they just tell you
something that keeps you in the initial
outrage
and that's it i'm going to try not to do
that so last week
you all heard the story of max public
house
this is a bar in staten island which is
as new york as you can get okay it's
just
perfect quintessential new york and this
guy wanted to keep his pub open
the police sent plainclothes police
officers there they shut him down
he tried to stay open they wouldn't they
wouldn't let him stay open
well then in the last couple days uh his
lawyer and his uh representative held a
press conference right outside
and uh listen to some of the stuff that
that mack and his guys are going through
right now this is video from fox news
de blasio and now cuomo have told the
people of staten island
new york city and the country that if
you speak up to the emperor
you get crushed in the last week just to
give you a timeline
lou gel amino one of the finest criminal
defense attorneys around and mark fonti
um who represent dan and mack max pub
uh lou was served with lewis charged
with a misdemeanor
for trying to be a lawyer our political
leaders came here to try to stand up for
the guys
and the restaurants and the movement and
andrew lanza was nearly
handcuffed in front of max pub for
trying to stand with the people
the other night we found out that it was
a political ambush
more details will come your way on
what's happened but it's a tale of two
cities
walmart just announced they're paying
700 million dollars in bonuses
and staten island restaurant owners are
getting arrested two times in a week for
trying to make a hundred bucks
the ignorance is so high that on
national television
they find it funny that small business
owners are trying to feed their families
while the millionaires sit in their
perch okay so
i'll reference that last line in just a
sec about national television and what
they're doing because snl just dropped
one of their painfully uns
on funny skits about about just that but
he said a couple things so that's the
representative for mac
and uh for the for the pub there that
they're going after lawyers
and again do you think that this
representative or this lawyer or mac do
you think that any of these people
wanted to be fighting the government
right now
what do you think these people want i
think they just want to go to work
i think they just want to feel that they
have a sense of purpose and they can
make some money and they can feed their
families
that's it that's it nobody wants to be
in this position
not the lawyers not the not the owners
not the people who want to go out and
live their lives
and we've got governments that are
coming they're coming for everybody and
we're just sitting there doing nothing
about it and and by the way
you know when this makes it to
mainstream news it's only to mock it
so snl saturday night live which was a
funny show about 30 years ago i think it
stopped being funny basically that last
season that phil hartman was there he
had that
phil hartman adam sandler when adam
sandler was funny season and then
and then uh ellen cleghorn was on back
then and uh
mike myers i think was on a couple other
guys and then it's just been trash
it's just left his trash now for the
last you know probably 25 years or
something
but this is this guy pete davidson who's
just deeply unfunny but don't take my
word for it
mocking the people who are trying to
live while he has a job where i'm sure
he's making hundreds of thousands of
dollars and has fame and everything else
so this is snl this past saturday so the
rule is that they're supposed to let
people eat or drink
outside and the owner said no one wants
to do that because they'll go out of
business
but the argument that people in staten
island don't want to drink outside can
be disproven by going to
literally any little league game one guy
at the protest
even gave a speech where he literally
compared not being able to drink indoors
to being jewish during the holocaust
which must have been awkward for the
people there who had to suddenly pretend
they believed in the holocaust
so i take it you found these protests
frustrating
yeah man they're making us look like
babies you know you know it's bad when
even people in boston are like ah
drink it home you queers
what did i just watch there people are
paid to write that i mean what
self-righteous drivel by put on a
[ __ ]
shirt you dick like these people are
awful they're oopsy i cursed
i cursed i was trying to remember what i
said on friday i was trying to
not curse as much because i was cursing
a little more last week that was a total
accident right there
but these are horrible people you are
mocking
the people who want to make a living
while you make i'm sure that guy makes
six figures there's no doubt about it
and he's been in movies and he's loved
by hollywood
and what is comedy comedy is supposed to
be punching up right comedy's supposed
to be you fight something
above you you you make a joke about it
what does a jester in a court do right
you make fun of the king that makes
everybody
realize they're part of the thing these
are guys these are people that are
punching down they're punching people
out of work and what was the implication
that people who want to go to these bars
don't believe in the holocaust what the
hell are you talking about these people
are absolutely awful and the reason it's
worth showing you that not that anyone
watches snl besides the
the blue check like twitter elite like
nobody watches it nobody actually thinks
it's funny
but you can feel the whole system the
whole awful system
that we've been fighting against for the
last four years you can feel it like
kind of
recalibrating right now and starting to
come back where snl
will now make fun of republicans and
regular people again
and we're gonna have all of the swamp
come back and all of these
loser middle management bureaucrats who
are all being let back in by biden
it's like the whole awful thing is
trying to come back right now i don't
know that it will come back i hope that
it doesn't come back and
i still i said we're not going to really
talk about the election today i still
think there's a lot of things
going on there we shall see but just
pete davidson if you're watching this
you're a horrible human being
who is making money by making fun of
people
who are hurting that's what you're doing
with your life
and and get get out of that hoodie and
put on a shirt
like you guys are just they're just
pathetic these people i don't care about
the hoodie it's not about the hoodie
these people are just like pathetic and
they're unfunny and they're paid to
write that crap to mock decent people
while decent people want to go to work
who are the good guys and who are the
bad guys and if you listen to mainstream
it's almost completely backwards
i'm going to guess that pete davidson
probably has more friends that are
closer to holocaust deniers than anyone
at that bar
figure out what that means i'm not even
sure all right let's move on
uh let's go back to this coast i'm just
bouncing all over america
today we'll have to do more in the
middle of the country we'll have one
from the pacific northwest in just a
minute but i need some stuff in the
middle of the country can you guys send
me some videos
uh this is sheriff bianco from riverside
county here in california
who has decided that he's not going to
enforce newsome's lockdowns and this is
what a brave
public servant sounds like sheriff take
it away
the dictatorial attitude toward
california residents
while dining in luxury traveling keeping
his business open
and sending his kids to in-person
private schools is very telling about
his attitude toward california residents
his feelings about the virus and it is
extremely hypocritical
these closures and stay-at-home orders
are flat-out ridiculous
the metrics used for closures are
unbelievably faulty
and are not representative of true
numbers and are disastrous for riverside
county
when the medical field is so split about
this virus
it might be time to employ a little
common sense
keeping money and support from our
hospitals who are struggling with normal
seasonal increases in patients coupled
with covid19 patients
is irresponsible it appears
part of the new goal is to shift
attention away from his
and others personal behavior with a do
as i say not as i do attitude
by turning public opinion against
california sheriffs
he is expecting us to arrest anyone
violating these orders
site them and take their money close
their businesses
make them stay in their homes and take
away their civil liberties
or he will punish all of us
i believe that all jobs are essential to
someone
leaders do not threaten attempt to
intimidate or cause
fear bully
sheriff bianco if you're watching this
you are a great man you are a great man
and i just want to say
that i for one and i think most good
americans we stand with our sheriffs we
stand
with our law enforcement i think blue
lives matter i think most of these
people
not even most i think 99.9 of these
people
are good people who go into this type of
public service to do
good as opposed to what happens to the
people that go purely into the political
side
who just want to control everybody and
never produce anything if you're going
into law enforcement
you know your life is on the line your
butt is on the line every single day
and i think these people deserve our
support what this guy
is doing is absolutely right he says a
couple things there he says the metrics
are unbelievably faulty well of course
we know that's true because it's all
random and none of it makes sense i mean
the most basic one that i
mentioned last week is that part of our
new lockdown
here in california is that museums
and zoos must be at 50 percent museums
virtually all
indoor zoos outdoors but they just okay
50
each one that makes sense 20 percent
real um
you know retail stores it's like they're
just making
up nonsense and we are all just going
along with it because you know what most
people don't want to be revolutionaries
i don't and yet here we are most people
want to go about living their lives but
they're literally
they are stealing our lives like this in
a weird way
oh one of the people at the at the rally
on saturday said to me one of the
business owners said to me this is a
fate worse than death
this is a fate worse than death and i i
kept thinking about that line like
like think about it death okay you get
shot you get taken out whatever it is
you get hit by a car
like it's over it's over maybe you did
something good in this world maybe you
didn't
maybe you have regrets maybe you live
like a perfect human being you
accomplish everything you want to
accomplish but this thing
where your livelihood is being stolen
from you in this restaurant owner's
estimation was a
fate worse than death that you believe
in something you give your blood sweat
and tears to something and someone
who should have no power over you is
allowed
to just take it away and i don't think
we the people are going to stand for it
much longer i just don't
he also said we need common sense a
little common sense
yeah that would probably be good uh and
then what i really loved is that he made
the point
uh sheriff bianco have made the point
that this is about shifting attention
so when garcetti does this and he's out
maskless at a rally you know a couple
months ago
or newsoms at french laundry these
people are shifting attention from their
failures by the way i just read this
morning
that garcetti is going to be on joe
biden's uh
incoming team like that's going to help
with the with the january 20th event
the inauguration event so it's like
he'll fly here and do that that has
nothing to do
with being the la mayor these these are
they're just genuinely horrible people
you know one of the things that i try to
do on the show and i think i mostly
succeed on it not just on the show but
in life is that i try to talk about
ideas
more than people so one you know i'll
talk about what people's
thoughts are what their actions are
things like that as opposed to going
after people but i do think it's
different at this
point with politicians which is why i've
directly called out these people and
i've got my
fake news man glasses when i do it that
these people
specifically must be called out they
must be called out because they are the
ones making the decisions i i don't go
after
i try not to really go after the pundits
that i disagree with or that sort of
thing i try to talk more about their
ideas
obviously i'm not perfect at that nobody
is um
but these are bad people so i just want
to say and by the way i said it there
were there were
group of great officers who were in
santa monica when i was
at the rally at sheila cool's house and
i went up to them and i thanked them
and uh and a few of them knew who i was
and it's like these are good people they
don't
want to stop anyone from living their
lives
and and basically it's it's we the
people versus the
the small amount of loud lunatics who
want to control us and and that's
what the battle of the future is and not
only that then you couple that with the
reality war that i'm always
talking about that half the people don't
see any of this stuff because they're
watching cnn
so anyone in your family that doesn't
watch these types of shows
they have no idea that any of this is
going on is cnn showing the rallies
like think if you were an honest news
organization
that woman out there that's newsworthy
that's newsworthy but what do you get to
see on mainstream you get to see pete
davidson make fun
of the people who want to live and man
this is this is
seriously dangerous uh let's jump to one
other video and then i promise if you
guys send me
some videos just tweet them at me at
reuben reporter it's it's best if you
join the reuben poor community and then
i have a much better chance of seeing it
if you see videos from the middle of the
country because i don't like that i'm
just bouncing a lot between
new york and la here or new york and
california but this is from bend oregon
and there was a rally to open up uh
oregon
right and that means that there are some
sane people still in oregon without
question there are it's just portland
that's gone completely bananas uh but
here is a woman who purports to be a
teacher she says she's a teacher
and she has a few choice words for some
of the people that just want to go back
to work and try to live their lives
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i am
[Applause]
hey
[Music]
ah it brings me back to third grade that
does remind me of my third grade teacher
i mean these the only reason i'm playing
that video i don't care about this woman
as a private citizen forget about her
but the point is if she is a teacher
like these
are the hysterical nut bags that are
teaching your children on top of the
fact that we have critical race theory
being pushed back into the schools
and the rest of it like there are
mentally unhinged lunatics
who often are are being pushed on us by
the teachers unions that are completely
out of control
at this point that don't even want to
work and in fact most of them are not
even the teachers aren't even working on
these stupid zoom things i mean i'm
hearing this from so many parents it's
ridiculous
um but i i'm really playing that video
if it had just been some random woman
screaming i wouldn't have played it but
the idea that this woman is a teacher
putting aside the the she dropped a
couple f-bombs so even if i hadn't
dropped the f-bomb before
the f-bomb was coming in this episode so
most likely there goes modernization
that's okay
um anyway it's important to know that
we're just watching so
much stuff kind of collapse right now
and i think
i think it is your job more more than
ever before more than any of us could
have ever
realized if you live in modern times
that you've got to be one of the ones
with the cool heads
you got to be cool calm and collected
right now and
and know what you believe and why you
believe it and if you want to find out
some of the things that i believe you
could check out my book because i lay
out all of this stuff and i was warning
about
all of this stuff for a long time um
anyway this was the special lockdown
edition of the reuben report direct
message
we are not going to be live tomorrow or
wednesday because
i am actually heading to dc to go to the
white house
that's right i am going to the white
house hanukkah party
which is on wednesday so i'm leaving
tomorrow uh
i'll be there tomorrow and wednesday so
we won't have live shows tomorrow or
wednesday but i may do some live streams
with the
with the trusty phone and i have reached
out to the press team
uh that's in charge of the president of
the united states and obviously we've
been going back and forth for quite some
time i'm going to see if i can get a few
minutes with him so maybe i can do
a little live stream from the oval
office or something we'll see if we can
pull that off
uh and then i'll be meeting some
interesting people in dc so we'll
probably have a bunch of content that
goes up over the next two days
but we will not have an in studio show
tomorrow
or wednesday uh but we will be back at
11 a.m
pacific 2 p.m eastern on thursday and
then of course on friday as well
anyway send me some videos if you're
seeing more of this stuff and you know
one of the things that i did in the in
the reuben report community this morning
was i posted just like what are your
thoughts on the world
because i think i can get way more
uh incisive interesting
pieces little nuggets of knowledge from
from regular folks than i can by
any of the pundit class and and
certainly anyone on mainstream media and
that that does help me shape
which way i should take this show and i
could just really feel this morning
that so many people are frustrated with
this lockdown and again that is not
to diminish covid but at some point
you have to figure out which one is
doing more damage
is it the lockdowns that have trapped us
in our house and kept us depressed and
rates of alcoholism
and everything else and people that are
unemployed and people who have nothing
just
nothing to do and don't feel any reason
to wake up
and everything else just on the whims of
politicians
or is it the actual disease think about
that for yourself
and then we'd probably start having some
answers all right guys that's it for
today
as i said dc tomorrow and wednesday i'll
do some videos and periscopes and a
whole bunch of other stuff and then i'll
be back in here on thursday
all right people ciao